[Music]
hello and welcome to Playstation
grenades Borderlands 3 is almost here
and whether you've been waiting seven
years for Borderlands 2 to get the
sequel it deserves or you're completely
new to this series let's break down
everything you need to know before
release day rocks up we have to start
with the new vault hunters each with
unique skills we have the choice of four
playable characters Amara Seine black
and Moe's I know what you're thinking
wow Adam hitting us with those knowledge
bombs and you gain with new characters
well well it's their abilities we should
grab your attention as each one will
change how you play the game each vault
hunter has three skill trees to choose
from Amara is a siren with astral powers
like holding a foe in space shooting
projectiles are badass ground-and-pound
moon for AoE attacks Mo's is a
straight-up soldier but she also has a
mech too known as the iron bear each of
her skill classes adds to that mech a
minigun a grenade launcher or a railgun
by the way the mech has a second seat
for your friends to join you flak is a
beast master he has a pet with him toll
times a scag spider ant or Jabba which
runs around and fight on your behalf
flak can also use an invisibility cloak
like those in the predator movies and
send out a rack or two for a quick
attack and then there's my personal
favorite Zayn from my playtests Zayn
brought me unbridled joy as he's the
only vault hunter who can assign two
skills simultaneously Zayn can send out
a clone to fight while he changes
position he can call a drone for
additional support and two barrier to
four defensive situations I realize
going through all those characters in 30
seconds is a bit difficult to understand
so come back next week and I'll help you
decide which vault hunter you should
choose on your first playthrough
[Music]
without a doubt the looped game is the
real deal in bottle answer three
supposedly 1 billion guns first of all
they feel great but how on earth that do
they actually make 1 billion guns well
it's pretty simple when a gun is created
in game it uses a pool of parts and
simply smashes different things together
and the results can be mind-blowing on
top of that depending on the weapon
manufacturer they will have core
attributes for example tdr guns can be
thrown away at the end of each clip but
how that gun behaves once you let go of
it is completely mind-blowing guns can
stick to walls guns can run on the
ground guns can bounce weird stuff but
it's so satisfying and new to the series
are optional fire modes by flicking down
on the d-pad your weapon could do
something completely different maybe a
simple auto fire maybe it's something a
little more crazy finding out is the
real fun although guns are randomly put
together using a loop table there are
hundreds of weapons in the game which
are not for example boss fights have a
chance of dropping fixed loot don't
think they'll be standard loot though
during my first ever gameplay session I
fought this Punk bigger mind defeating
this boss could gift us this a weapon
which throws out a brain on legs and it
actively hunts down enemies too if
you're looking for a realistic game
I don't think bottle and three is really
for you
[Music]
which leads onto humor quite well the
character of Badal and three is
slapstick and it's very under nose with
its comedy for example we all know the
importance of coolant don't we well in
Borderlands
they have Heaton's yeah this kind of
comedy is all the way through so be
prepared to grow and some jokes here's a
comedy test what do you call a sad
strawberry a blueberry your reaction to
that joke is how you will react to most
of bottle on three there's one part
where you'll find an AI units and attach
it to a robot's junk yes it's just it's
just weird in a good way Bob line three
is the first game in the series to take
us away from Pandora yeah we went to the
moon in the pre-sequel but this time
around we have multiple planets to cause
havoc on each with unique flora and
fauna the sprawling metropolis of
Promethea feels worlds away from Eden 6
which is like a volcanic swamp world we
are also likely to travel to locations
hinted at in previous iterations in the
story we know about Athena but now we
could be going there too so how the heck
do we get to these new planets and
locations by using sanctuary of course
sanctuary is no longer a small town in
Pandora now it's an intergalactic space
station sanctuary 3 is more than a
simple hub though this place is your
home all the characters you meet and
talk to can be found around the ship
claptrap crazier of Ellie the list goes
on sanctuary also evolves along with the
story campaign claptrap will become a
bug on the windscreen at one point
Marcus will offer you new upgrades to
your guns and sir hammerlock will ask
you to slay beasts which then become
room ornaments here
this place is impacted on by your
actions and the story progression oh and
the best thing of all if we happen to
leave some loot behind during a crazy
boss fight it will appear here no more
missing loot bloody awesome speaking of
new mechanics Badlands 3 introduces the
slide mechanic you've seen in many other
games probably apex legend is the most
well known and we can also now vault on
objects pulling ourselves up to ledges
we couldn't in previous games in the
series barrels and interactable objects
in the world have been tweaked to make
them more useful in situations such as
exploding
things dropping objects from above and
even setting the odd oil spill on fire
lovely in terms of time you'll spend in
the game the campaign is said to be
around 35 hours in length depending on
your play style but that doesn't include
all the collectibles and side quests
some places don't even impact the cost
story but we'll still need exploring to
discover everything this game could last
hundreds of hours the borderlands 2
community is still going strong today
seven years after it released and that
leads to my next point golden chests for
numerous years now Borderlands has done
something absolutely incredible due to
the random nature of loot drops it's
possible to use loot keys in-game to
gift yourself a weapon or gadget from
the sacred golden chests the keys work
at any point but once they're used
they're gone the loot is then linked to
the level they are opened at so if our
level 22 siren opens the chest the
weapon will drop around that level great
if you get stuck on a certain boss fight
tactically though players tend to hoard
these keys until they've maxed out their
rank making the keys a source of endgame
loot it's great isn't it but it gets
better than that
the Borderlands Twitter account amongst
others regularly tweets out cold to
grant more golden keys but they must be
redeemed within a day or two but once
you have them redeemed you can stockpile
them to your heart's content
well back to bottle ons 3 they've taken
this function to the next level VIP the
vault insider program by creating an
account over in Borderlands com we can
take part in insider activities which
award points here's my account once we
accrue enough points we can claim
rewards I've opted for all the
alternative color scheme skins for the
main characters but there is so much
more to choose from there's golden keys
for the previous games there's weird
masks and oh I think I'll buy that one
and spend enough time here and you'll be
rewarded with a legendary gun in
Borderlands 3 I'll be sure to place a
but ton of codes in the description
below if you want to get some free
goodies just in case you don't fancy
searching the internet for them
[Music]
let's go back a step to the end game if
you played Borderlands 2 you remember
the badass ranks for playing beyond the
end of the game it was like an infinite
way to rank after the game finished well
this system has been tweaked yet again
and is now known as The Guardian ranked
Borderlands very own Paul sage said this
about it in Borderlands 3 not only has
infinite progression but it has skills
and different skins that you unlock as
you go through and the cool thing about
that is every character that you play on
in that account gets the benefits of
Guardian rank so we can safely say if
you choose to play through as different
characters on your account then the
skins and unlockables will be given to
all characters across your entire
account pretty cool more endgame content
includes the return of the circle of
slaughter basically a hard mode for
Borderlands which has wave after wave of
enemies running at you quite
aggressively then we have something
called proving grounds an arena based
trial with optional objectives the more
objectives you complete the higher the
loot with higher chances of unique
weaponry these trials won't always be
easy to find in each scenario for
example the player must locate codes
from an unnamed alien race before taking
on their trial under their watchful eye
and I'm calling it now the final trial
will have a space off with an alien
queen
[Music]
so have you decided if you're going to
play alone or with friends if you decide
the latter know that in addition to
online play it's possible to have
split-screen co-op on console the ps4
and the Xbox one I'm old enough to
remember how great split-screen used to
be it's great to see it in a modern game
and speaking of playing with other
people Borland 3 will use an instant
loot system in the past when a gun
dropped in Borderlands it was a race to
get there in front of your friends
because whoever got it kept it and the
others just felt sorry for themselves
well get this instance loot will give
every player their own unique loot pool
no one can take your stuff away from you
take your time with it no need to rush
your friends can't run past like a
vacuum cleaner and take everything in
sight if for some reason you prefer the
old system simply flick the switch in
settings this also makes play between
lower level players and those higher
rank ones much easier let's get down to
a bit of money Borderlands 3 will have
micro transactions but don't worry these
will be in the form of cosmetics
costumes and visual changes we have been
promised there won't be any pay2win
schemes here Borderlands 3 does want
more of your money though but they'll do
that through DLC drops there are many
characters cut from the core game it has
been hinted that the DLC will see all
characters return giving us time with
them once the core story has been told
DLCs will also increase the level cap
and introduced new weapons
so if Borderlands 3 floats your boat you
may want to think about purchasing DLC
afterwards oh and as an extra point
raids are confirmed to return after the
game launches not completely sure if
that means part of the DLC
are free editions later in the game's
lifespan we shall see so when does the
mayhem begin not long now September the
13th so that means now we need to go
through every single version of the game
which one will you pick up let's do this
as always the standard edition contains
the core experience a gold weapon
trinket and gold weapon skins that are
applicable to all guns in the game will
be included no DLC in this one you'll be
able to decide on that later then we
have the deluxe edition which wants more
of your money in return for everything
you've just heard plus the neon cosmetic
pack the gearbox Cosmo
tech pack toy box weapons and equippable
XP and loot drop boost mods so
technically there is pay to win the
Super Deluxe Edition is next which has
all the things we've just gone through
plus all for DLC campaign expansions
featuring new stories missions and
challenges there's also a weapon skin
trinket and grenade mod all based around
the legend that is but stallion and
finally the bottle and three collector's
edition I've tried and failed to buy
this three times so far by the way it's
pretty damn rare it includes everything
we've just gone through plus there are
real-life physical items within this
collector's edition it comes in a huge
hulking diamond loot chest replica
within that are 10 bot lines 3 character
figurines there is a snap model of the
sanctuary 3 there are 4 vault key
keychains there's even a cloth map of
the entire galaxy and to finish off
there are five arts lithographs of
characters in the game and all that for
only 250 dollars well huh if you buy the
game on the epic store you'll receive
the borderlands 3 character bundle for
fortnight which usually costs around $20
also if you do it through the epic store
please think about using my code a
damaru
as I get a kickback on the purchase and
I use it to give things away to the
grenade community and finally the
technical stuff if you're a PC user I'll
throw all the specs in the description
below but if you're on ps4 pro or xbox
1x you should know that you have
additional options to prioritize
resolution or framerate so you could
have 4k at 30 frames a second or my
personal favorite 1080p at 60 frames a
second woo
we did it thanks for your time it's much
appreciated I'm Adam from Playstation
grenade come talk to me over on Twitter
I need more digital friends I'm Adam
grenade over there I'll be back next
week with more badlands 3 content see
you soon
[Music]